[Applaus]
deutschlands viertgrößte stadt köln hier
lebt eine familie die zunehmend genervt
ist vom großstadtleben schon länger
träumt sie vom leben auf dem land ein
traum der jetzt immer weiter form an et
bénédict jacobs hat das traumhaus für
seine familie bereits geplant ein plan
der in der stadt kaum umsetzbar wäre
[Musik]
von der stadt können wir uns das
grundstück dafür nicht leisten dass
kosten zwanzigstel von dem was es hier
zum beispiel in köln kostet dafür für
das reihenhaus vier jahren bekommen wir
auf dem land ein freistehendes haus und
möglich wurde der traum vom neuen haus
erst durch ein ereignis das die ganze
welt verändert hat so als jetzt corona
kam war auch bei uns in der firma
natürlich home office angesagt und wir
haben dann auch bei uns in der firma
gemerkt das home-office auch
funktioniert und wir haben office alle
machen können ohne dass die leistung
zumindest bei uns in den bürojobs leidet
unter die einstellung auch bei meiner
firma hat es jetzt 180 grad gedreht home
offices akzeptiert noch unter 40 jährige
mit seiner frau nadine und den drei
kindern in einem reihenhaus im kölner
stadtteil porz home office und corona
haben den alltag der familien nachhaltig
verändert sie verbringt die meiste zeit
in den eigenen vier wänden
nadine und benedikt sind beide auf dem
land aufgewachsen
der im hunsrück in rheinland-pfalz sie
in thüringen
kennengelernt haben sie sich in köln der
reiz der großstadt hatte vor jahren auch
sie gelobt
als ich im dorf noch gewohnt habe wollte
ich erst mal weg natürlich wenn man dann
18 19 ist dann erstmal die stadt das
auch am anfang ein super tolles leben
man konnte war einkaufen gehen man das
essen gegangen und in bars und kneipen
gegangen und wir jetzt so mit der zeit
merkt man ja dann auch mit dem alter das
man ruhiger wird dass man das also dass
ich das gar nicht mehr so brauch ich bin
sehr frei aufgewachsen und ich möchte
halt auch dass meine kinder frei
aufwachsen können die andere kleine
katze ist so alt wie ich sie besucht
mich jeden tag das macht spaß mit
einander zu balken wehrmacht noch so mit
corona und lockdown wurde das leben in
der stadt für die familie immer mehr zur
belastung und das obwohl sie ein eigenes
reihenhaus hat benedikt und nadine
fielen vor allem die
ausweichmöglichkeiten abseits des
eigenen zuhauses
sie stören die vielen menschen überall
und der viele verkehr und so wurde aus
dem wunsch irgendwann wieder aufs land
zu ziehen ein immer konkreteres vorhaben
wir hatten dann ja auch die zeit uns
darüber gedanken zu machen weil dann mal
nicht jeden abend oder jedes wochenende
irgendwo action war dass wir andere das
für freunde besuchen gefahren sind übers
wochenende oder freunde zu uns kamen
sondern wir dann auch mein wochenende
hier für uns allein waren und einfach
die zeit hatten uns über solche dinge
über solch ein schritt gedanken zu
machen diese sehnsucht begleitet uns
schon so viele jahre wir haben das nie
gemacht warum drehen wir jetzt den spieß
mal nicht um und sagen wir machen das
und wenn wir das jetzt nicht gemacht
hätten dann würden wir uns vielleicht
irgendwann mal fragen warum haben wir
das nicht gemacht und das würde ich
traurig finden
und deswegen steht für familie jacobs
jetzt fest wir wollen hier raus wir
wollen hier raus aus der stadt raus aus
dem hasenstall indem wir mehr oder
weniger wurden reinen mehr platz familie
jacobs macht sich heute auf in die
zukünftige heimat sind 149 kilometer ich
freue mich jetzt noch mal zu unserem
grundstück zu fahren zu sehen wo wir hin
bauen werden bis unsere ruhe oase sagen
wir flüchten
gerne hin schon jetzt fahren sie sooft
sie können in ihre neue heimat in
hunsrück fast zwei stunden fahrt liegen
nun aber erstmal noch vor ihm
laut einer repräsentativen umfrage
können sich 41 prozent der
stadtbevölkerung grundsätzlich
vorstellen auf dem land zu leben
nur 30 prozent schließen einen umzug
aufs land für sich aus 29 prozent können
es sich vielleicht vorstellen
dabei sind die wichtigsten gründe für
einen umzug weniger lärmbelastung der
wunsch nach mehr natur ein eigener
garten und günstigere wohn und
mietpreise
ist das neu gewachsene interesse am land
nur ein kurzer hype oder wirklich
zeichen eines gesellschaftlichen wandels
in berlin institut für bevölkerung und
entwicklung untersucht susanne däne die
bevölkerungs bewegungen in deutschland
der dörfer oder der ruf des landes hat
sich in den letzten jahren merklich
verbessert wenn man sich ansieht wo zehn
menschen weg wo ziehen menschen hin
profitiert aktuell der ländliche raum
und vor allem das umland der städte das
hat einfach auch damit zu tun dass die
städte stadt gewachsen sind in den
letzten 20 jahren es voller geworden ist
es enger geworden ist und es einfach
auch teurer geworden ist neu ist das
städtische phänomene und strukturen wie
coworking spaces und gemeinschaftliche
wohnformen deutschlandweit auch immer
mehr auf dem land entstehen
landlust 4.0 nennen forscher diese vor
allem digital motivierte bewegung
digitalisierung ist ein möglich mache
dieser neuen land bewegung weil
digitales arbeiten als unabhängiges
arbeiten macht es für viele der die sich
jetzt neuerdings für das landleben
interessieren eigentlich erst möglich
diesen wunsch auch umzusetzen was neu
ist sind auf digital arbeitende kreativ
und wissensarbeiter ein milieu das man
bisher in den innenstädten in den
zentren vermutet diese menschen
interessieren sich oft für
gemeinschaftliche wohnformen auch in
entlegenen ländlichen gebieten wie sieht
es aus dieses neue digitale leben auf
dem land
brandenburg eine stunde südwestlich von
berlin
auf diesem ehemaligen gutshof in klein
glien einem 80 einwohner dorf befindet
sich das coconuts ein sogenannter
coworking und co living space gestresste
großstädter können sich hier einen platz
zum arbeiten inmitten ländlicher idylle
mieten und die unterkunft gleich dazu 20
leute hast du maschine genau große
abstände einfach friends uraufgeführt
wird das coconut von der amerikanerin
julie ann becker ihre man janosch
dietrich und iris wolf durch corona
haben die drei deutlich weniger gäste
momentan kaum 20 trotz corona
beschränkungen dürfen sie gäste
beherbergen da diese zum arbeiten kommen
die leute kommen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen einige bleiben
nur für eine nacht weil sie etwas lesen
müssen
oder sie müssen ein projekt zu ende
bringen also kommen sie gezielt für ein
zwei nächte um konzentriert arbeiten zu
können
wir haben auch gruppen die für ein oder
zwei nächte kommen die in einem
strategiepapier arbeiten und dann haben
wir leute die für ein paar wochen oder
sogar ein paar monate kommen wenn sie an
einem längeren projekt arbeiten
auch svenja nette hat es von der stadt
hierher verschlagen
die 35 jährige kümmert sich um die
hühner auf dem gelände
sie schreibt einen eigenen blog über
ökologische landwirtschaft
zehn jahre lang lebte die gebürtige
westfälin in berlin
das hat mich immer gezogen der gedanke
an land ich habe mit ein paar leuten
auch zweimal schon versucht einen ein
hoch projekt zu gründen das ist dann aus
verschiedenen gründen wieder geplatzt
mittlerweile denke ich mir ist
eigentlich ganz gut weil irgendwie muss
ich selber erst noch mal rausfinden was
ich eigentlich will auf dem land und
dafür ist coco hat eben einen total
schöner zwischenraum eine art land leben
auf probe also die gäste im coconut
kommen momentan vor allem aus der nahe
gelegenen hauptstadt trotzdem sind sie
alle sehr unterschiedlich
jeder hat seine ganz eigene geschichte
ich schätze dass coconut total weil der
raum auch wenn man das vielleicht so
nicht vermuten würde
mit sehr vielen verschiedenen leuten
voll ist also man trifft hier eben
gerade nicht nur die typischen digital
arbeiter und arbeiterinnen sondern
wirklich auch echt sehr unterschiedliche
menschen die vielleicht gerade eine
doktorarbeit schreiben oder die in dem
projekt auf die beine stellen was
eigentlich mit dem digital arbeiten als
solches gar nichts zu tun hat und ich
glaube dass die menschen die hierher
kommen er irgendwie zusammen führt ist
so ein ja eben diese sehnsucht nach land
und überhaupt mal rein zu fühlen wie ist
das kann ich damit und kann das mit mir
und sich darüber eher treffen
ein besonderer gast im coconut ist
google torschüssen der 52-jährige
unternehmer stammt aus island er
entwickelt eine digitale lernen und
arbeitsplattform speziell für deutsche
schulen und ist eigens dafür nach
deutschland gezogen
in brandenburg ist der isländer eher
zufällig gelandet
ja ich bin vorher in berlin gewohnt und
habe dort seine wohnung gemietet als
untermieter dort und dann lief man
vertrag aus und deswegen bin ich
hergekommen wollte hier nur ein paar
wochen bleiben dass sich eine neue
wohnung finden würde
aber dann hat es mir einfach so gut
gefallen dass ich habe mich entschieden
hier erweiterte bleibt hier habe ich
viel mehr
juli war eigentlich immer überzeugt der
städter doch inzwischen genießt er das
leben auf dem land und die langen
spaziergänge mit seinem hund und
ständigen begleiter kultur
ich bin ich aufgewachsen habe ich meine
stadt gewohnt und hatte mehrere liegt
nie so gedanken darüber gemacht
auf dem land zu ziehen aber das
verändert
hallo sagen rechtlich sind ja genau
für neun jahre ja andrea klein ist denn
klein glien aufgewachsen
die wiederbelebung des alten gutshofes
durch coworking findet sie gut
überhaupt übernimmt wenn es mal ab und
zu hat los und wo und diese diese
konzepte diese haben also doch finde ich
sehr schön eigentlich auch die anderen
dorfbewohner begrüßen das projekt denn
zuvor hatte keiner wirklich was vom
größten gelände im dorf der gutshof
stand über mehrere jahre leer
den jetzigen betreibern ist es sehr
wichtig die dorfgemeinschaft mit
einzubinden
wir haben die wünsche der dorfbewohner
sehr ernst genommen
die freiwillige feuerwehr sollte ich
hier sein sie fragten ob wir das
dorffest ausrichten
sie haben uns um ein paar dinge gebeten
und wir haben sichergestellt dass all
ihre wünsche erfüllt werden
es war uns sehr wichtig dass wir offen
sind und in der dorfgemeinschaft hier
akzeptiert werden und wir möchten dass
sie sich hier willkommen fühlen sie
nutzen vielleicht nicht unseren
coworking space aber sie nutzen unsere
räume für andere dinge
dinge die zu ihrem leben passen
viele gäste bleiben deutlich länger im
coconut als geplant sowie skulpturen und
sein hund chor ich bin im kopf und jetzt
seit einem jahr
dort kam ich letztes jahr und dann
bleibe was ja nicht noch einige monate
auf jeden fall die wohnungssuche in
berlin hat der isländer zumindest
erstmal auf eis gelegt
die kölner familie jacobs hat sich
bereits entschieden ausland zu ziehen
sie ist auf dem weg in ihre neue heimat
[Musik]
nach fast zwei stunden fahrt haben sie
ihr ziel erreicht ihren traum vom leben
auf dem land peterswald im hunsrück 180
kilometer südlich von ihrer bisherigen
heimat köln
[Musik]
cg ist einer von 800 einwohnern in ihren
zukünftigen heimatort an frisch
gekauften baugrundstück schmiedet die
familie zukunftspläne ich freue mich auf
den großen esszimmer bereich wenn unsere
familie da ist dass wir platz haben wird
es nicht so eng ist die großzügigkeit
der sechs meter breite reihenhaus
sondern und 15 meter breite frei
stehende halten und hat platz für zwei
autos wieder kriegt ein auto wieder
mussten auto klinger
wenn alles gut läuft kriegen wir ein
tool da freue ich mich drauf haben so
impulse bringen
[Musik]
zum grundstück wäre ja gar nicht
bezahlbar gewesen können das muss man ja
dazu sagen
oder müsste vielmehr weiter raus fahren
aber dann müssen wir auch 30 gewinn
daraus können dann sind wir auch auf dem
land becker wurde hier hin wo wir wo wir
unsere wo ich meine wurzeln habe und
meine familie er ist wunderte sich auch
sehr wohl fühlt denn ohne diesen
familienanschluss hätten die jacobs in
peterswald kein grundstück gekauft
nur ein paar meter entfernt vom
zukünftigen haus wohnt benedikt cousin
thomas jakobs mit seiner familie sagt
man für uns wir haben wir leben ja hier
schon seit kindheit
wir haben auch immer mal wieder überlegt
in die stadt zu ziehen aber sind
trotzdem davon weggekommen weil ich weiß
nicht ob gerade mit kindern das angebot
was man in der stadt hat ob man das
erstens so wahrnimmt und zweitens ob man
das auch gegenüber dem land so schätzen
kann weil hier sind andere qualitäten
die uns wichtiger waren dann im
endeffekt
nicht nur die nähe zur familie ist für
die jacobs entscheidend gewesen sondern
auch die ganz besondere landschaft also
als ich das erste mal hier war als für
mich das erste mal im training genommen
hast da hat mich das hier geflasht also
dieser ausblick von denen habe ich ganz
lange immer geträumt mit den vorgestellt
werden peterswald denke denke ich immer
an diesen ausblick
nadine und benedikt jacobs haben hier im
hunsrück ihren traum vom leben auf dem
land gefunden
die sehnsucht nach ländlicher idylle
sie ist so stark wie lange nicht auch
durch corona das gewachsene interesse
der städte am land bringt neue probleme
aber auch neue chancen mit sich ob die
verstärkte lust aufs land mehr als nur
ein vorübergehender trend ist wird sich
erst noch zeigen
[Musik]